uh we have been
man this is this is really bad
we have been talking about how
the modern
reactionary movement i don't call them
conservative there's nothing
conservative about them the modern
reactionary trumpian movement
is dangerous
and we learned that
when they kidnapped the governor of
michigan attempted to kidnap the
governor of michigan sorry correction
we learned that
when they did all the things they did on
january 6. these these are dangerous
people
and there is a man who posted videos to
tick-tock
showing himself
hunting for quote
non-binaries
non-binaries by which i imagine he meant
people who identify from a gender
standpoint as non-binary or transgender
that's my understanding of what this guy
meant tiktok has removed the videos but
it's been widely downloaded and we have
it
and we're going to look at the video
and it is going to be disturbing
not because there's any gory images or
anything like that but it's disturbing
because it is another reminder of how
dangerous these people are
this man
shows himself carrying out what he calls
a snipe hunt
demanding non-binaries
be turned over to him
okay
and he says if he finds people meeting
his criteria
he will load them into the back of his
vehicle transport them presumably
against their will which we would call
kidnapping he doesn't say they're going
to want to come with me
and he would bring them to a hospital
for treatment
this would be very illegal let's take a
look at the first video as if we need
like the extra details he's wearing an f
joe biden hoodie in the video as well
take a look at this the man i guess goes
by the handle steel walker 42 live
and believes he's doing the lord's work
take a look at this this may come off a
little transphobic but it's not
it's not
i'm doing lore's work i'm trying to help
people i'm here to get all the
non-binaries i'm at the motel 6 right
now we're starting here and we're going
to get all the non-binaries picked up
put them in the back of my truck and
we're going to take them
to a hospital if you have
we're going to get all the non-binaries
let's go i bet i need to get the back
anyway
all right
we're going to get all the non-binaries
right now
if you see a non-binary
snatch them up if you got any
non-binaries i got to pick them up
and i got to take them you don't need to
see my id i need to see where the long
binaries are i don't understand where
they're hiding are they [ __ ]
camouflaged they got that binary
camouflage
are there any non-binaries in this hotel
because if because it's far that's a
problem right there we got some let me
out this one
he's asking about
where are the non-binaries
this is terrorism
this is terrorism you know i stopped
short the other day
of saying
certain things we were looking at are
terrorism because i'm not sure
this is terrorism this is going out
there and saying
based on your membership in a group the
group would be
trans non-binary i guess everything that
falls under that umbrella this guy
doesn't like and saying we're going to
round you up and we're going to take you
in now he's not saying we're going to
kill you
he seems to at least have the common
sense to know that would be even more
too far so he says we're going to take
you to treatment at a hospital
this guy has previously posted videos
encouraging others to quote go hunting
and implied
that those who identify as non-binary
should be shot here's the second video
then if you want to go hunting
get out
get out into the deep woods
and you can you'll see a lot of
non-binaries running around
everywhere just jaw jacking
indoctrinating everything the wildlife
catch them hoes
so
good for tick-tock for pulling it down
this is not free spree free speech
you're threatening crimes here
a number of different crimes that's
number one but
this is scary
i can't even imagine if i was trans or
non-binary or had anything other than
what this guy
sees
as the acceptable
identity traits
i would be scared
i would be scared and to be perfectly
frank
we were talking about this on our live
stream over the weekend
i don't know if the solution would be
flood the red states with progressives
to sort of like push these people out or
at least make them not want to go out
and do this stuff
or is the solution to get the
progressive the hell out of these places
and get people who are lgbtq plus out of
these places for their own safety i
don't know i don't know the solution
but this is
extraordinarily disturbing
and it is difficult to think
as someone who's not part of these
groups
it's really difficult for me to imagine
the the terror
that folks must be going through
when guys like that are around hopefully
police are investigating i don't know
for sure i will find out and let you
know
we'll have these clips if you're only
listening today and you have a sort of
morbid curiosity about what the guy
looks like and what he's doing we'll
have these clips up on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
we'll take a very quick break and be
right back
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well
chili sleeps product the uhler the cube
and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get 30 percent off of the
uhler and cube sleep systems and 10 off
the new dock pro this offer is only for
my audience the link is down below